now about the structure so it's it's
it's quite simple and uh it's uh it's
kind of flows from one session to
another and that's what i wanted to
cover in uh today's presentation mainly
that uh what what will be done
throughout the program so we will start
with the basic sessions where we
discussed about the um the uh the
structure what are the different types
of protein structures what are the
interactions where do you find this
computational resources for protein
protein interaction
conformational analysis protein folding
some of the basic concepts how this
happened and what are the computational
resources associated with some of the
prediction tools or some of the analysis
tools not prediction here because we are
doing a prediction a different session
uh dedicated to predictions but here we
are
going to discuss more about uh how to
you know find the tertiary structure the
secondary structure and build from there
then we are going to introduce first we
are going to discuss about big molecules
macromolecules and then we are going to
discuss about small molecules in the
same
prospect
that how to obtain and understand about
small molecules where do you find such
data what are the different ways to
understand this data what are different
ways to express this data in the
databases how to find this on all of
that so these are basic overview
sessions and then from here we go to the
actual databases and we start exploring
those databases because it's very
important to understand what is
available on public repositories
because you want to maximize and utilize
the public data and if you have
propriety data that is an added thing
that you can do in a research project
but in the terms of education and
learning we will be using the public
repositories and where
you will see that people are publishing
uh
almost thousands of articles
based on the analysis that are available
through the public repository and public
data so here there is an aspect of
hands-on activity which would involve um
use of some proper some free softwares
which uh where for which we will be able
to we will be able to share with you how
to install them and then show you how to
work on them so also we will be sharing
uh emails throughout this training
program so uh the emails will contain
information about the coursework but not
only the post work but also publications
and link to all of the uh all of the
databases that we are covering and the
and the certain uh repositories that we
are going to use so all of this is like
building up to the uh knowledge of how
to
first of all understand about the data
and information and then where to find
it and then how to download it and
visualize it and uh in this process we
will be using a lot of case studies from
rc us rcsb pdp and we will be using
protein data bank
by to
compare structures and to understand
that what we what are the experimental
structures that are available for our
problem if there are no experimental
structures what would be the strategy to
model such uh such cases in such cases
and then like how do you connect from
different uh protein
like different complex interactions
because now with a lot of single
structures the world is now moving
towards the complex uh complex structure
of complexes where more than one
proteins are involved in in certain
biological function which is greatly
are associated with diseases and
mutations and all so we will be
discussing some case studies and then we
will be working on such
such data using the rcsb pdb protein
data bank where all the experimental
structures are available
so integrating this information
you can also
work on your own
project here so one of the idea is to
use
the structures that are available and we
will be able to do some search uh
searches based on the queries so here i
was as i was asking uh earlier
to share the project form so the project
form will involve uh that will include
the description about the protein of
interest and if there is literature
available on it so that we can start
working or start developing a proposal
now after doing that like when we
understand that where the structures are
how they how they are available and what
are the ways to visualize it
and uh what uh how where how can we
compare and align and see the statistics
so one of the important aspect of you
know comparing and writing a publication
or writing a report or showing uh this
to the community requires some
statistical uh validation through tools
and through different analysis so that
statistical validation is something that
we are going to cover in that which
involves root mean square deviation when
we compare structures in angstrom uh
unit and all of that and then we are
going to move to the session next
session which is more on target
structure prediction
where we are going to use uh
the structure prediction tools so this
is a critical part of drug discovery
okay m informatics based drug discovery
for
preparing the receptor because uh
i mean one of the objective what you're
trying to do is you're trying to mimic
uh the
mimic what is happening within a cell or
within uh
within a uh system so
you want to make it as close as to the
actual uh actual
environment that in which the structure
is so there are certain tools that we
are going to use we are going to
understand from a plus point of view of
structural biologist if the structure is
making sense and if the structure is
properly modeled and to do that we
want to validate one of the ways to use
multiple uh
multiple algorithms so we are going to
go get some hands-on activity on that so
the session is sort of divided in this
way so target identification processes
then
what are the what are the actual
meanings as i was
describing you about target
identification and it goes in like
really really depth then we have protein
structure prediction why and how then
comparative protein modeling and alpha
fold and then there is a working session
so uh comparative protein modeling we
are discussing about a template-based
modeling so template recognition how can
we find templates and find the right
kind of template because sometimes we
are trying like in in drug discovery
there are open there are different
confirmations for protein right and then
there are different ligand-bound states
and when you look at the structural data
you'll find a lot of variations there
how to understand that and use that in
your experiment is very important so
that alignment back and then when we are
looking at the structure when we are
looking at a model then we are looking
at different components of the secondary
structure that has been modeled uh which
involves the loops that play a critical
role in many of the binding processes
whether it is maybe a small iron or a
metal line or or
or a ligand so loop modeling side chain
modeling model optimization model
validation some of these aspects that we
are going to discuss
and then uh use some of these modeling
tools which are very famous and used
utilized by uh
by the entire scientific community who
are working on the similar area such as
modeler or alpha fold so we will start
our alpha fold predictions from here and
understand what are the challenges
limitations and uh how can
this uh the predictions uh make sense in
biological context and if not what are
the solution strategies for that
so after target prediction uh the the
thing that one would want to learn about
is that yeah right i have now a good
system
good biological system to test on i have
prepared a good target and
it mimics what what is happening
it mimics almost of what is happening
within so we would want to now
understand that what are the solution
strategies so here onwards we are
discussing about the solution strategies
the virtual screening is one of such
strategy that is that is going to be
utilized and understood in this session
which is the session five which is where
we are almost at the midway so uh like
uh virtual screening can also be
optimized because the the the databases
have millions and billions of compounds
small compounds and you don't want to
you can't actually
use all those all of those
molecules to screen at on on a single
protein or
multiple targets or whatever because
it's going to take forever and then also
it's computationally expensive and
extensive and expensive so you would
want to do a lot of optimization a lot
of you know knowledge based uh
screening so that's what we are going to
discuss in target identification and
then we have some case studies uh which
we have worked with uh in our in um in
our research projects with the with
our collaborators one of such project is
roosevelt park cancer research institute
where we worked and uh one of the
molecule is
uh is being utilized for uh treatment
and is effective so how does this
process happen
what are the different ways we did the
screening
we utilized the topper research platform
and then uh based on machine learning
and representation and clustering
we kind of reduced the
chemical space to a significant space
where you can actually now test test
them low so you would want to reduce the
chemical space from thousands and
millions of compounds to maybe 100 or
500 or 1000 and then you do more
intensive testing
virtually before finalizing top 10 or
top 100 for your experiments
now uh then as i was saying that after
virtual screening it comes to very
specialized kind of screening which is
the
part where we discuss about molecular
docking
and it's a very popular pro
method and many of you might have been
aware of it and might have used it
already
but in this uh in the session we uh dr
puneet uh who has already prepared a lot
of sessions for you who will be
participating in the program which are
pre-recorded sessions uh for specific
tutorials that we have for this for this
uh session six which is practical
experience and docking where we will be
covering like tools such as argus lab a
highly featured molecular modeling and
graphics program
which works on windows and the program
contains two docking engines with a
small
with a scoring function which is very
much used which kind of gives you an
estimate of binding affinity uh so maybe
k a combining association or something
you can correlate it with uh uh in uh
for the validation like uh if you're
comparing number of molecules which
would be the you know top 10 or how do
you filter them so
these are the tools that are used and
useful to filter them based on their
based on their binding and interactions
with the even your protein molecule so
this is what we have planned uh and then
we have an interesting session which is
uh again now from
from structure now we are using more and
more about how we can do this at a
scalable
way by applying uh
statistical uh tools such as art
language or are our
coding so this is quite simple because
all of this is done in google collab
notebook which we will be sharing with
you and it has all the tutorials and you
can play the notebook and take up and do
the different steps and this is you know
why this is we are doing this this is
like you did the virtual screening where
you identified from a large library of
molecules into
and get leads
so after getting leads you you got maybe
top 10 or top 20 leads and you you are
looking at the
top poses and you're analyzing and
you're checking the interaction but can
you optimize it further so for
optimization what you need is something
that are
that medicinal chemist expert in that
chemist are working working in that
changing the different orientation
changing functional groups and doing
more drug optimization so this session
actually helps in those who are into
drug optimization so chem informatics
and using r
and those google column networks you can
generate different confirmations and
change it by by just changing few
sentences or the group information in
the in the notebook so all of this is
quite uh automated and it's really easy
to use and that's one of the objective
for creating such a curriculum so that
it's easy to use and implement and later
once you
gain expertise and more and more
expertise you'll be more easy and
comfortable to go for advanced research
so uh after this we have an uh
discussion on a case study so this is a
case study based uh um session uh
by one of the experts from an industry
to discuss about the drug discovery
process the high throughput process the
structural biology screening and some of
the case studies
which is to discovery of a kinase
inhibitor for lung cancer so we will
have a pharma expert
from from the industry discussing about
this
uh after that we we are in during this
process
are going to discuss or share with you a
lot of publications that would make
sense for you to develop research ideas
and encourage you to develop research
ideas if you don't have already one uh
so in this uh uh towards the ninth
session and we are towards the
last three sessions of the program we
are going to discuss advancements in uh
ai based molecular drug discovery so in
in this session we are going to deep
dive in more in um into the alpha fold
predictions so alpha fold uh you know in
a way uh they have already predicted 200
million structures uh uh this is the
news that i've heard like couple of
weeks ago uh so all the unifor uniprot
protein sequences are now modeled so you
can uh simply utilize those and then
based on uh
all of that there are some limitations
still there that uh you know that alpha
fold is not able to solve so what are
those limitations for example the
structures for which there is no
information at all like noble structures
obviously alpha fold can't solve the
struct uh
give you solution for that because it
does not have the training or the
training on such data so what are the
solution strategies and what are the
different uh case studies in terms of
how pharma and computational biology
companies are
utilizing this uh
ai in molecular drug discovery how
academy and industry is utilizing this
ai and drug discovery and how we can as
a researcher or as a scientist or as a
student uh can uh incorporate or
get some of this technology in and use
it for our own research uh many of them
open source or if we can develop
something using the resources that and
with our mentors
so um as i was telling you about uh the
ai introduction so uh as alpha fold i
was telling you that they have now open
open it for open access this open access
open access database is available for
all of us and we will be downloading and
we will be looking at that so some of
the limitations that i was telling you
in the previous and to the previous
slides are listed about here actually so
different versions of alpha fold and
then there are uh
in biology you will find um
some proteins are functional as uh as
multi multimers so how do we do
complexes so i was telling you that this
is a challenge and uh this is something
that uh people are trying to solve
especially structural biologists who are
working on specific problems especially
working with research groups who have a
biological background and they are
conducting experiments and knowing from
the uh from the
illusion that what is the
what is the weight and based on the
molecular weight uh how many um how if
it is a multimeric protein or there are
different ways to know that
so from that information can we
can can we produce
those models so again to the same point
that i've been discussing for a while
the correctness of the model is pretty
important and it should include all the
biological information and insights that
we know of
so the more we can build that uh closer
to the biological information the more
the chances are for us to get the right
kind of result so alpha fold on that and
then mutations so there's a huge huge
challenge with mutations so i've been
working on many projects which involves
mutation obviously with covariate and
all the
cancer mutations so how do you
understand what are the structural
changes how how do you capture the
structural changes because what you are
seeing is just a snapshot this is not
the complete picture so here the you
know uh application of molecular
dynamics simulations and
normal mode analysis
and then different types of
wholesale simulations comes into picture
and that would be maybe a research topic
or as a research that one can do
so uh as we've been discussing about uh
the same thing so in the context the
case study that we will be discussing in
this uh will be a pharma company who is
utilizing the information
and the
deep learning processes for not only
screening and all of that but for new
molecular
new molecule generation using graph
theory and using deep learning so how
they are utilizing this and uh what are
the different uh solutions that they
have come up with because uh many of
these are we thought many of these are
experimental but what are the different
uh situation in the market if it is it
is
it is going to be successful or not if
it is what stage it is in so those are
the different uh those are the that's
the case study that we have that we are
going to discuss
and then we have uh the session on uh
data warrior which will be discussed
towards the end of the program
where which is to you know understand
all of this so we i just discussed that
calculation of key chemical properties
generation of new chemical compounds and
identification of chemical
representation so before that we discuss
about the case study so that you know
that what is the application and then
you have you are excited to learn this
yourself
so uh that would be what we are going to
cover in the advanced game informatics
session uh which is the last i think uh
one of the last sessions and then we
have some of the case studies uh
which is very important so uh at the
beginning of all of this we will be
start we will be we'll be working on um
we will be working on the project form
so if many any of you have a project
idea and you want to work on our project
next session we are going to discuss
about the research projects so what are
the chem informatics research projects
how to design a chemi information
research projects what is the different
stages challenges and limitation and
then the omics logic research fellowship
so this is towards the end so anyone who
has been working on a project i would
want to develop a project and work on
that can work with me we can work with
dr raghav can work with the industry
experts dr neeth
which would be through the home's logic
research fellowship so this is the 11th
uh session uh more about
what are the next steps that one can
take so we have several of these case
studies integration of homicide into
research projects pharma projects for
bio biomolecular or biomarker discovery
so these all come boils down to the
structure of the protein and
understanding so these have the chemo
informatics component and then the kobe
19 case study uh where we are discussing
understanding the different uh binding
domains and then strategizing based on
the structure and what are the different
uh
ways to look at infectious disease
research so one of the things that we
have been discussing is about all of
this in the respect of uh protein
structure so protein structure as it's a
organic
molecule with a lot of
chemicals uh
forming the structure and there is also
a component of electrostatic uh
distribution the charge distribution the
hydrophobicity what are the different um
phys
physiologic or physical properties of
the amino acid and how does that make a
difference when it comes down to you
know um binding so this is all knowledge
based and this can be gained through the
simple structural analysis by utilizing
some of the tools that the structural
biologists or computational structural
biologists utilized and i will be able
to share some of my knowledge and
information that i've gained and worked
on
and
on the publications that i've been able
to publish so far so i'll be able to
help in that and then we have the last
session which is more about uh
the
about a case study that what are the
examples of successful and failed drug
discovery development by one of the
industry experts uh to know and
understand that what are the
different things that we have to look
into when we are discussing about drug
discovery and what people have done and
what they have learned so far from this
experience so that's uh that's the
entire structure of this uh program and
i hope that many of you would be
interested in doing so
throughout the training program